was the movement I was raised in one of
those Ms you understand but I had to
walk away because I saw how we
completely ignored black people's
problems we completely ignored Black
Culture we completely ignored the black
reality it was all Islam learn your
Arabic and I'm like I'm up I'm a
practicing Arab I'm not practicing Islam
I'm practicing arabism why do I got to
learn aab language to worship God why do
I got to eat like the Arab to worship
God why do I got to dress like the the
worship God this is not the worship of
God this is the deico of Arabic culture
and that's why I walked away from it and
now African spirituality is my
Foundation the name of Allah the
beneficent the
merciful I want to respond to a a clip
someone sent me by Dr Omar Johnson where
he was mentioning some of the reasons
why he left
Islam claiming that Islam didn't address
the problems
of the black
community and he mentioned that he in
fact wasn't learning Islam he was
learning
arabism and he said why do I have to
learn the language of the the Arabs in
order to worship
God you know and so he's casting blame
upon Islam for these
reasons in response to this
first and foremost as it is well known
amongst all Muslims and even many
non-muslims is that the
religion of all the prophets and
Messengers was
Islam and then many proofs for that from
from those proofs is the statement of
Allah in his book and were you
present when death greets y Jacob and he
said to his sons what will you worship
after it said we
worship your
God and the god of your fathers
ibraim Abraham is
is and is
Isaac one God
alone and we are submitting as Muslims
to
him so this shows right here
that the religion of all the prophets
was Islam and it's known that Jacob
wasn't an Arab or Arab as he says nor
was ibraim Abraham nor
was ishmail and nor was Isaac but they
were all
Muslims uh that's from one
perspective another
perspective
is it is as if Dr Omar Johnson believes
that
that there is only one type of worship
or
one act of worship within Islam which is
the prayer which is said in
Arabic and no doubt this is
false as for worship in Islam is a
comprehensive term for everything that
Allah loves and is pleased with from
statements and
actions so there are many acts of
worship from that is the prayer the five
obligatory prayers from that is fasting
from that is Hajj from that is Charity
from that is slaughtering from that is
vowing and sacrificing from that as
obedience to the parents and many acts
of worship in
Islam and
no no one
from According to my knowledge these
Scholars of Islam said all these acts of
worship must be done in the Arabic
language fact fasting how would that
even be done in the Arabic language yeah
this is the act of worship you're
worshiping God by fasting by withholding
from food and drink
charity these these acts of
worship they don't require the Arabic
language nor does supplication calling
upon Allah asking Allah for your needs a
person can call upon Allah in their
language n the obligatory prayer the
Salat which is one type from the types
of Acts of worship in Islam yes it must
be done in the Arabic language this is
how the prophet
Sall legislated it that the prayer be
done in
Arabic but that's one act of worship
from the many acts of worship so for him
to say and it shows his ignorance of
Islam the reality of Islam for him to
say
that how how do
I why do I have to
worship God and the language of the
Arabs
that's not precise at all and it
shows that do Omar Johnson is ignorant
and misinformed of the reality of the
religion of
Islam and no doubt the Arabic
language although it's not required for
all acts of worship just as I clarified
but no doubt Arab the Arabic language is
from the religion because the Quran was
sent down in the Arabic
language the Quran was sent down in the
Arabic language so the Muslims Muslims
all over the
world Indonesia Malaysia all throughout
Africa North
Africa and
likewise many other countries in Africa
many of them may learned the book of
Allah meaning in the Quran and they
recite it and they learn it in the
Arabic language as it was
revealed as it came
down from Allah to angel jbel from Angel
jbel to Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon
him and Prophet Muhammad he taught it to
his
companions and from the companions of
prophet Muhammad sallallah alaihi
wasallam from them
were blacks from them were Persians from
them were Arabs from them were Romans
and further Allah he
mentioned oh
mankind indeed we have created
you from male and female and we made you
tribes and Nations so that you may know
one
another indeed the most
noblest of you in front of God in front
of Allah is the most Pi so in Islam is
not about a skin
color it's not about a skin color
it's about the one who has piety in
front of God no matter they're black no
matter no matter if they're white no
matter if they're Arab no matter they
non
Arab so these are just some
doubts
from Dr Omar Johnson that I'd like to
quickly
address and we ask Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
to guide
him to that which is correct and keep
the Muslims firm upon their
religion and all praise due to
Allah Lord of all creation